well so this book the first
chapter is do not casually denigrate
social institutions or creative
achievement and i picked that quite
carefully because again the liberal
types are more likely to criticize
social institutions so
you don't want to do that casually
because they structure things and
protect you in a way that you're likely
not even aware of
and the conservative always says look be
careful
when you change something because you're
changing a bunch of things and you don't
know what's going to happen
so be careful
but social institutions can become
corrupt even just as a consequence of
aging
and so they have to be updated so they
can't stay static but that doesn't mean
you shouldn't respect them and then
creative achievements on the other side
and conservatives for example they have
a harder time with
open people creative people you know the
best personality predictor of of
liberalism is high openness which is a
creativity dimension well it's easy to
dismiss art for example
[Music]
as especially if it doesn't exactly
speak to you but it's through artistic
endeavors through creative achievement
that the process of update occurs
and so
regardless of your political temperament
you need to see these
these forces
you need to see the value in these
forces and have some respect for them i
think what happens if you get educated
hopefully is that you get educated
beyond the confines of your temperament
so
so so that's why i thought your the
ordering it's so interesting that you
you said you intentionally of course you
intentionally did it but that so do not
carelessly denigrate social institutions
or creative achievements so that's
chapter one and i thought it was
interesting because you know one of the
things that i've been talking about for
the last couple years but especially in
the last year and our friend ben shapiro
wrote a whole book about it is the
disintegration of so many of our
institutions
and that i think the
the great debate right now is can some
of these institutions survive or do we
need all new institutions now i know
you're talking about social institutions
not just academic institutions or
you know we're talking about cultural
institutions
what do you what do you feel in the in
that argument whether can some things
just be left to disintegrate and we
rebuild or do we do we constantly end up
in a destruction and a rebirth
because right now we're watching so many
institutions just just crumble
well i tend to start local when i'm
thinking you know so the because it
simplifies things well the first
institution is the sovereign individual
we don't want to let that crumble
and the more that you're able to live
in a relationship with truth
i would say the better job you're doing
of protecting your integrity as a
sovereign individual start with that
it would be a shame to lose the family
people derive a tremendous amount of the
meaning of their life from their family
and then those intense relationships i i
don't think we can get beyond that
um
i think you have to knit your family
together
to the best of your ability and i know i
know that people often have terribly
fractured families but we don't have a
good substitute for that
um
you need to exist in relationship to
your culture you need a job or a career
something like that we need political
institutions
i i think part of the problem of course
is that everything is changing so
rapidly that it's very difficult to
it's very difficult to say what should
be kept and what shouldn't be yeah and
and we're not in control of it to some
degree as well
i mean there's in this all-out assault
on the integrity of of cultural
structures but there's also a
technological assault on everything
and so
what do you do in a situation like that
well i think my my sense is you revert
to the individual
how much of this try to make better
people how much of this do you think has
to do with the speed because actually i
remember
on sort of the last maybe quarter of the
tour one of the things that you talked
about a lot was how the internet was
changing us how the speed of information
was changing us how how you as a random
person no matter where you are in the
world you might be able to send out a
tweet or create a meme that could change
the world
like that
so how much do you think the speed is is
all part of this in ways that were
literally unimaginable three decades ago
i think it's a tremendous part of it we
don't know what to do with any of the
new technologies that we've produced and
by the time we adapt to them they'll
have transformed into something
completely different
so
you know my my kids are in their late
20s and they're
more a part of the internet generation
than i am
but
there being supplanted in their
knowledge by younger people already they
can both feel it
it's changing unbelievably quickly
so
that that that
puts a tremendous amount of stress on
everyone
when you talk about the the creative
achievement part of this one of the
things i've been thinking about lately
is that
i don't remember the last time i heard a
new musician that i really loved or saw
a piece of art that was new that i
really loved you know it seems so rare
we because of what's happened with
cancel culture that the people that
should be
showing us things are not showing them
um
what what do we do about that like how
do we make the artists brave again how
do we make the people who will give us
the creative achievement how do we
make them see that star again well you
do you do whatever you can by example
that's the best that's the best
you've got
you know so hopefully you try to bring
integrity to your
to your endeavors and
hopefully that has a salutary effect you
don't have it you don't have a better
option than that
the first rule that you talk about
jordan is not to carelessly denigrate
social institutions or creative
achievement and here this is really a
post-partisan message it's a recognition
that conservatives respect for tradition
respect for the past is really a respect
for institutions that have been built up
over the course of thousands of years in
conjunction with a an increasingly good
understanding of human nature and that
has to be balanced with a a recognition
that we can't get so tied up in these
rules that it becomes impossible to
extricate ourselves from them we can't
we can't fossilize these rules and turn
them into uh something that is that is
unchangeable in any way that in essence
we should be cautious about changing the
rules of society they should be
changeable so we shouldn't obliterate
them but we also have to you have to
know the rules of the game before you
can change the rules of the game and if
you're playing uh if you're playing
calvin ball and in calvin and hobbes and
the rules of the game change every
second that's not a game anymore that's
just an exercise of power but you also
have to recognize that sometimes the
rules do have to change how do you
balance those two things well i think
the first thing you do is vow to tell
the truth
so that you don't follow yourself up
and then i think you
pay attention to what manifests itself
to you as meaningful
because i think that meaning i literally
think and i think this empirically as
well as spiritually let's say
i
believe that the instinct of meaning
signifies the optimal
information processing function of the
nervous system so when you're balanced
properly between order and novelty
or order and chaos
that that manifests itself to you as
deep engagement
and that's a signal
and it's not merely cognitive it's way
deeper than that it's a signal that
you're in the right place doing the
right thing at the right time and
everyone wants that and everyone wants
that all the time
like images of paradise are
representations of that state of being
so it's there for you
but
but they're preconditions
and one of the preconditions is that you
strive to do
the best
to aim at the best and that has to be
your fundamental ethos that and it's a
decision that despite all of the
calamities of being
that your primary ethical
obligation is to work for the betterment
of yourself and others and that's a very
complex decision because there's so much
of you that's twisted and turned against
existence itself because of its
suffering and complexity it's very hard
to get your head straight about that and
so you get warped and twisted by
resentment and
and and deceit and and temptations of
various sorts so that has to be
straightened out so that you're aiming
in the right direction and
and
once once you manage that or perhaps in
conjunction with that you have to watch
what you say
you have to say what you believe to be
true not because
you're trying to accomplish something
specific with what you're saying but
because you're attempting to represent
what's happening
in front of you as accurately as you
possibly can and let go of the
consequences
and so and then
you search for this you search for
this engage you search for the
engagement that that produces
and this is one of the things i love
about long-form podcasts
is that when a conversation
takes off properly and it's dynamic and
unscripted
both of the participants are striving to
keep that sense of engagement constantly
at play and if they do that then the
conversation is engaging and deep and
gets as deep as the people involved can
manage and they'll pull the entire
audience along for the ride and everyone
is thrilled about that that's logos
that's the manifestation of logos
and it's deeply meaningful it's there's
nothing more meaningful than that
and that's just that's a sign that
you've got that balance right you want
to be there all the time that's the goal
is to be there all the time
of course that's a lofty goal
and and very difficult to attain but
but that's that's the end game well
first of all
let's not get too
casually critical about the idea of
conformity i cover that in chapter one
do not casually denigrate social
institutions or creative achievement
it's like it's really hard to get
everybody on the same page
and it's really hard to get everybody to
conform especially when they're doing it
voluntarily and there is not much
difference between that and peace
and if you don't think that that's a
good thing then you should think really
hard about failed states where no one's
on the same page and you get an instant
proliferation of
warring gangs of armed thugs and
if you think the utopians are going to
win the armed thug battle you've got
another thing coming yeah because
they'll be the first ones on the
chopping block
and so
you know you're you're a comedian and an
open person and not likely to have a
great taste in some ways for pure
conformity and
and
i'm someone who enjoys artistic creation
revolutionary ideas but by the same
token
i'm not someone who despises conformity
you know well you said in the book i
mean you said that we're always going to
have as humans we're always going to be
searching for revolutionary ideas it's
something that
um is constantly the way that we've
always been and it's the the way of like
just a a liberal way of thinking is to
keep moving forward and progress and try
things that are new and want to do that
but
i just feel like you have to have a
foundation of comfort to be able to do
that from
because some of that is
a luxury of being comfortable
um or at least
tremendous amount of enough um and to
feel at all and when things get really
uncomfortable that feels a lot scarier
place to be creative from almost
well the first thing we should point out
is that
being a conformist isn't
the highest of moral virtues but being
unable to conform is worse
now refusing to conform that's in a
different category you might have valid
reasons for especially if you're
exceptional and you know you could say
well
virtually everyone is exceptional in
some regard and should perhaps not be
conformist there and we could say fine
but the rest of the 95 percent of them
should
go along with the crowd because
that that's going along with peace
and
we also don't ever want to confuse the
inability to conform
with the ability to produce
revolutionary ideas
because just because you can't conform
or are rejected doesn't mean you're a
genius
what it most likely means is that you're
just incapable
and then you're going to be highly
motivated to confuse your incapability
with creativity
and that's not helpful and then you
pointed out something that's also very
important um
just how many dimensions do you want to
be exceptional on anyways you know
you're you're a comedian and you have to
take substantial risk to do that and
it's quite threatening it wouldn't be
such a bad idea if the rest of your life
was
well maybe secure enough to allow you to
tolerate that
yeah
yeah to have some more sense of yeah
like um
i guess i worry on like a bigger like
picture as a nation that like if we
start to like
if the fabric of some of the textile of
the past if some of the tapestry kind of
i guess or tapestry of the past starts
to come apart
like i'm all for making new tapestry but
i just feel like i just get scared i
don't know if i feel
but it's more a fear
i get scared that if we do that that
things could just tear and and
i just don't know what's going to happen
i guess i'm just i'm scared a little bit
i don't know
what the future of this country that i
live in looks like and i used to feel
like i had a little bit better idea
but i don't know if the idea of what i
thought it looked like
was
just a
comfort based upon
like my skin tone and growing up with at
least food in my house you know i i you
know some stuff like i just don't know
if
i don't know if maybe my idea was just a
luxury or something i i don't know
do you know what i'm kind of saying a
little bit i'm just kind of yeah well i
think that's a question that's a
question that everybody's being driven
to answer partly because there's intense
moral pressure to ask yourself that
question you know to what degree was
your privilege unearned
well there's an easy answer to that
actually
lots of it
yeah but the same holds true with
virtually everyone else yeah you know
and so
um
who's who's got privilege
depends a lot on what group you're
willing to use as a comparison yeah yeah
so um
even impoverished people in
in north america
are rich by world standards yeah yeah
they're in the top one percent generally
speaking
and they're certainly in the top 1 by
historical standards the problem with
with
hammering home the idea of undeserved
privilege is that
there's no one who can't be
crucified on that particular cross right
right you know unless you're born naked
in the middle of a field with nothing
yeah everyone is the undeserved
recipient of
of the fruits of the past
the fact that you have a mother is is a
privilege
you didn't earn that
and so
when you say
you deserve nothing because of your
privilege
what makes you so sure you're not saying
that to everyone for all time in which
case no one ever gets anything that they
are
that they can have for their own
so it's a very dangerous game
well i don't see where it can end it's
not it's not obvious because imagine
each person is multiple has multiple
identities that's
intersectionality we all have multiple
identities
you're privileged along some of those
identities and
relatively speaking and less
along others
so if you're young and black and female
well you're young
right so
so
that's not deserved it's not like you
earned being young
and so right right right right right
right right right right right right
there is going to be some way
of there's always going to be some form
of privilege in every regard yeah i
certainly didn't feel privileged growing
up i mean i feel like a lot of what i've
had in my life has certainly
been earned um i felt disadvantaged in a
lot of ways um you know emotionally and
some
there's always yeah i think everybody
would have their own uh discussion their
own like
not their own parameters but yeah i
could see how everybody would have
pluses and minuses
well that's why i think the right level
of analysis is the individual
you know and when you move away from
that it gets dangerous it gets dangerous
quickly and it gets dangerous for
everyone and and the the reason why is
the reason that you just laid out you
take any individual person
you can point to the advantages that
they had now look i understand that some
people i mean i was a clinician for a
long time and i saw people who had lives
that were so hard that you can you could
barely even imagine it you know i had
one client who was
impaired intellectually
um
uh
she had a she lived with an aunt who was
schizophrenic who had an alcoholic
boyfriend who was extremely violent and
also schizophrenic who used to bother
her about being possessed by satan she
was so
um
uh i hate saying shamed ashamed that she
couldn't look anyone in the eye she
would walk down the street with her hand
like this sort of bowed down
because she felt so um
so
unworthy
she wasn't an attractive person she
looked like a street person so people
treated her badly all things considered
now look
she i saw her at this
hospital that i was working at
where the inpatients were people who
were in even worse shape than her they
were people so hurt that they couldn't
be de-institutionalized
and i saw her because she had decided
that she wanted to take one of these
institutionalized people for a walk when
she was out walking her dog
so despite all her
her catastrophes which were
plenty
you know she could still see outside of
herself
to someone who had it even worse it was
really something you know yeah well and
so this privilege game it's like
well
look to your own privilege
and that isn't i'm i'm not saying that
there aren't
historical injustices
but of course there are
many of them right there are for
everyone in a lot of ways yes but if we
only look at the victim side of things
anyway even as a human if i only see
myself as a victim i'm really going to
have a tough time i can see myself i can
respect that i'm a victim of some things
but if i only see myself as a victim
it's going to make the rest of my life
pretty tough i feel like
well i know it also enjoys
it matters what you want to do about the
fact that you're a victim
you want to take away from other people
you know right it isn't that and that
i don't know i kind of put us on a lot
of different planes here at once
oh that's okay well that was a very
complicated problem and it's one that
you know i think is particularly
uh relevant to your particular country
at this particular time and place
because that the tapestry is under
assault and the thing is it's a lot
easier to burn something up or to cut it
up than it is to knit a new tapestry
it's really hard
and
has there been i mean is it
is it okay where we are right now from
an outsider's perspective is it scary
like based on like historical
um civilizations and stuff like
do you think we're in a place that is
like still kind of safe judging from an
outside like or from a you know i mean
you're still in western civilization
canada's not extremely different than
the us
um
do you feel like we're in a scary place
or do you feel like
it's just a lot of pomp and circumstance
and at the root of things we're we're
we're still at a very uh realistic place
i think there are always
dangers that threaten the stability of
societies
i think that those dangers are real
but i think they're always there
i think that
i have faith in the robustness of
say american institutions all things
considered
it seems to me that
you your country has weathered crises of
at least this magnitude and often far
worse many times in the past and
and that's worked out um
so
i think there's reason to be alert but
not hopeless i mean on the broader scale
the broad scale
world scale let's say
it's hard to make a case that things
were ever better than they are now
and it's almost impossible to make the
case that there was ever a time in the
past where things were getting better
faster than they are now
so
it's
reasonable to assume
that
everyone on the planet will be out of
abject poverty as defined by the u.n by
the year 2030.
wow it's half well it already have from
2000 to 2012.
and so
and that was the fastest transformation
in human history by a huge margin yeah
i've been seeing less poor people i feel
like honestly
well there there's there's variance
because in the western countries that
the working class hasn't kept up as well
as they were in the 60s let's say in
some ways
but
globally speaking there's lots of
reasons for optimism but it's a
difficult problem to
settle because there's always the
possibility that any given problem will
get completely out of hand you know
that's the the case that people make
with regards to climate change
you know well there's a small percentage
of complete
a small percent probability of complete
catastrophe well we don't know what to
do with a problem like that
because it's impossible to calculate how
many resources you devote to something
that's absolutely catastrophic but that
has a small probability of occurring
right right you know like what if the
greenland ice sheet melts right well
then the oceans rise you know multiple
feet
and that's a catastrophe well how much
is it worth to stave that off
it's very very difficult to calculate
yeah and plus we're still a lot of
people are still surviving a lot of i
think there's still that a heavy
survival instinct in a lot of people
where
it's more of short-term survival that i
don't even think it's it's our fault for
thinking that way it's just built into
like our limbic system or our brain stem
or something like
it's hard it is yeah
it i agree with you it's an archetypal
story that's the apocalypse
yeah you know
the end of the world is always upon us
you know i said well go on sorry doc
well it's because things can fall apart
for us completely
and they do in our own life there's
illness waiting there's death waiting
like we we have a built-in sense that
things can come to a cataclysmic end
and it it
and that also makes us prudent and
careful and able to look at the future
and first all catastrophes but the
problem is is that we can also generate
false positives and be unduly worried
about things that are very unlikely to
occur yeah
so what is the template for constructive
criticism of a social institution in
other words if there is a wrong way to
do it where you're creating a void and
not offering a better solution
what is the
what is the better
approach or what might be
you know i got
well known
i suppose in part because of my
injunction to people that they clean up
their room
my closet by the way is a mess i haven't
been able to clean it up for like three
years
so um
there's this english common law
principle with regards to the
distribution of power
i think it's english common law
that there are certain responsibilities
of the family and the community in the
town and the state and the and the
federal government and the international
organizations and but you want to
have the
most proximal level
possible take responsibility for a given
enterprise
and i think that's a good
philosophy personally
you want to make changes start with
what's under your control
start with changing those things that
will hurt you if the changes go wrong
there's a good one you know and it's
better i think to put your life together
than to go worry about
parading around
and being a social activist
i think most of that's fraudulent and i
i think it's appalling that
students learn or people learn to do
that mostly at universities i think it's
it's it's it's appalling
fix up your own life
and that doesn't mean you shouldn't be
involved in the community but i believe
that you you have to earn that right
not only not because there's something
more wrong with you than wrong with
anyone else it's just that
you don't want to
if you if you operate at a level that's
beyond your competence all you're going
to do is make catastrophic mistakes
practice locally till you're competent
and then if you dare
move out a little bit you know as you
mature
and you gain some
when i when i used to work for the ndp
the socialists back when i was 14 or 15.
one of the things i came to realize i
think i realized this when i was 16 and
went to university
it's like i woke up one day and i
thought
i had this ideology in my mind you know
about how the world should be structured
and i woke up one day and i thought what
the hell do you know
you don't have a family you don't have
any experience you don't have a job
like you're a pop i mean i was smart
enough i verbally
could hold my own and my head was full
of ideas i could defend them
but you know at the same time that i was
a socialist
kid i was i sat on the board of
governors for the local college
and almost all the people on that board
were
local businessmen most of them
immigrants because northern alberta was
an immigrant
like it was only 50 years old everybody
had moved there it was a new place it
was the end of the frontier literally we
were at the end of the railway the
northernmost tip of the north american
prairie
and there was all these conservatives
sitting on this board and me and
what i found was i actually respected
these people
like i didn't i wasn't
my ideology my explicit ideology was
antithetical to theirs but when i
interacted with them one-on-one i
thought
these people have made something of
themselves
and
when i talked to the activists
i never got that impression i thought
you guys are resentful as hell and you
don't know anything you've never done
anything but you're noisy and
self-righteous and so that put a lot of
cognitive dissonance that filled me with
cognitive dissonance